[Música]
eu tenho muitos privilégios na vida
um dos maiores da minha família sempre
teve uma família muito unida e muito
amorosa
meus pais sempre presentes mas irmãs
sempre minhas melhores amigas e as
pessoas que conviviam com a gente falava
assim que a gente parecia família de
comercial que parecia tudo perfeito
perfeito mas ela quase sabe esse espaço
de muita alegria
só que eu perdi isso tudo com 16 anos
com 16 anos ela assumiu lésbica
eu estou a falar da minha sexualidade
para a casa cair
minha mãe falou que não tinha mais razão
para sorrir
ela não queria mais viver em que o maior
medo dela havia se concretizado e foi
expulso de casa nessa época a situação
piorou quando quatro anos depois eu me
dei conta que não era sua bissexualidade
era sobre identidade de gênero
eu não sabia o que era transexualidade
mas quando eu soube
eu me deparei com dois sentimentos muito
intenso eu senti muito conforto e muito
medo
eu tinha um conforto imenso por saber
que tinha um lugar pra mim vou saber que
tinha um nome para tudo aquilo que eu
sentia que de uma forma de você tudo que
eu sempre quis desde pequeno
olhar para o espelho e ver um menino só
que eu senti muito medo porque essa casa
já tinha caído como lésbica que
aconteceu agora como pessoa trans e de
fato foi muito difícil nesse período da
minha vida marcado por muita rejeição de
pressão e meus maiores traumas vieram
desses anos ter uma ideia às vezes
quando eu ia visitar meus pais a minha
mãe não queria me olhar eu chorava de
mvp que falava que minha imagem chocante
mas eu permanecesse ali eu queria
conversar o que insistir em 2007 eu dei
mais um passo na minha transição
eu fiz a mastectomia cirurgia de
retirada de ser assim que eu saí da sala
cheguei no quarto estavam meus pais meus
irmãos meus cunhados e meu pai pra cima
de mim e ele perguntou assim você aceita
suas irmãs como suas madrinhas
eu tava meio grogue por causa desse dia
pergunta não faz o menor sentido e ele e
minha mãe completaram em seguida falando
que a partir daquele momento seria
batizado nova
e que eu seria bernardo para isso também
eu faço análise tem um tempo e eu indico
na lista pra todo mundo sempre me fez
muito bem aqui querendo espalhando e uma
das coisas que eu vi na análise é que é
importante o bernardo existe pra mim que
eu não dependia de existir para o outro
para existir de fato não dependia mas eu
subestimava o com transformador seria
existe isso nos quais também naquele
momento primeiro momento que eles
pronunciar o meu nome foi tão importante
pra mim que eu tive a sensação de que
todo esse programa tinha acabado mesmo
eu falei nada de ruim vai acontecer mas
nunca mais e eu fiquei meses sentindo
assim normalmente os nossos sentimentos
são muito efêmero nesse sentido oscila
menos sente mais
eu não eu fiquei meses acordando e
dormindo feliz eu estava no ônibus um
carro começava contemplar a vida fala
cara que bom que eu tô aqui sabe que é
maravilhoso que ali né
é claro que em algum momento é passar
como passou a enxergar problemas
acho que seria difícil chegar em 2019
não vê coisas ruins mas foi muito
importante porque foram dez anos dez
anos do momento em que assumir lésbica
até o momento a minha cirurgia 10 anos
torcendo muito para ter minha família de
volta 10 anos conversando chorando
gritando com muita paciência
eu tinha em casa a pessoa mais
preconceituosa que eu já conheci
pessoalmente tenho tanto por aqui é pior
mas felizmente eu não conheço mas a
minha mãe é essa pessoa
minha mãe não era um monstro do
contrário é mas sempre teve um coração
imenso ela sempre foi uma mulher muito
boa muito atenta outro muito doado muito
generosa
então a conta não batia como que aquela
mulher estava rejeitando o próprio filho
sabe mas ela não se dava conta que era
uma rejeição ela achava que tava me
colocar no caminho do bem
a minha mãe saiu do lugar de uma mulher
que já desceu do carro para chegar duas
meninas que estavam se beijando e eu não
era uma das minhas eu estava no carro
com ela uma mulher hoje mãe que defende
a causa e que abraça a causa e que fala
para pessoas desconhecidas que tem um
filho trans
ela fala com orgulho
o amor pela minha família mudou muito
meu olhar para o mundo é muito frágil
ano isso mas eu de fato o projeto meus
pais nas pessoas
então quando alguém é preconceituoso
comigo alguém que eu desconheço
eu não tenho esse tipo nossa que é
escroto eu penso senão as pessoas deve
ter algo de bom está sendo equivocada
escolta falam e eu sei que pode parecer
realidade quem gosta de astrologia pode
falar que meu sonho sestário que me
deixa muito otimista
ou pode parecer que estou relativizando
o preconceito eu não tô eu acho que o
conceito algo muito grave mas eu acho
que tem formas de combatê lo
eu acho também que a gente tem que
entender o que cada um dá conta
tem gente que não dá conta de ter
apanhado tanto e ainda dialogar
tem gente que tá tão machucada que não
quer mais ter que ensinar como se
tratava a gente tem que respeitar cada
lugar
a forma como eu olho mundo é confortável
para mim porque dessa forma teve várias
surpresas muito boas
um dos últimos amigos que eu fiz foi um
cara que tava trabalhando comigo ea
gente estava almoçando no primeiro dia
assim ele não sabia que era trans
ele me olhou e achou que fosse um
moleque de 16 anos e esse é um dos
benefícios testosterona que eu tenho
quase 30 já e aí nessa conversa a gente
ele começou a ser muito machista começou
a falar do lugar de um homem que é ser
homem então eu falei então a sua trança
e aí ele tinha vários pensamentos
preconceituosos sobre isso
só que a gente não tinha escolha o que a
gente estava numa fazenda a gente ficar
15 dias lá trabalhando junto a gente era
uma dupla de trabalho é um trabalho que
considero muito simbólico que a gente
estava construindo um muro junto muro de
pedra sempre a cavalo e no final desses
15 dias
eu saí aprendendo tanto com esse cara e
ele saiu questionando a
heteronormatividade refletindo sobre o
machismo e me prometendo que defender
pessoas trans se eu visse alguém falar
alguma coisa
o mérito não é meu o mérito é do diálogo
pra mim o diálogo tem esse poder de
transformação
eu dou palestras sobre a identidade de
gênero e sexualidade em escola e
faculdade eu chego sempre aberto falou
que as pessoas podem fazer perguntas que
elas quiserem
às vezes eu me arrependo do que eu
respondo algumas coisas mais pesadas mas
sim uma pergunta que sempre parece as
pessoas sempre me perguntam qual é o seu
nome de verdade
qual é o seu nome de registro
aí eu respondo qual era o meu nome de
registro mas eu completo falou olha não
fazer esse tipo de pergunta pra outra
pessoa sttrans
ela provavelmente vai sentir se chamada
nome verdade um nome com que ela se
apresenta é assim que ela quer ser
chamada não se entende que sua
curiosidade pode gerar constrangimento
pode ir a incomoda
eu sempre tento ser muito didático para
falar porque eu percebi que é impossível
separar diálogo de didática que para
fazer entendido eu tenho que falar de
uma forma que eu entender eu não podia
falar com a minha mãe sobre binarismo
seu performance de gênero esse tá
teorias acadêmicas sobre o assunto
eu tinha que falar a linguagem dela pra
mim comunicação nada mais é que traduzir
a minha linguagem para a linguagem do
outro
só que para saber da linguagem no outro
tem que olhar para esse outro eu tenho
que minimamente saber que ele pensa que
contexto que está inserida
só assim eu vou ter mais chance de usar
as palavras certas para traduzir pensar
nessas múltiplas linguagens me fez
pensar sobre múltiplas verdades ou
verdade nenhuma teve uma vez uma
palestra que ele estava na sala e uma
menina trouxe sobre a escola das
princesas
é uma escola que ensina meninas até a
reputação ensina sobre a importância do
património ensina como cozinhar para os
futuros maridos ea sala apesar de
maioria conservadora a sala ficou
indignada com esse projeto
aí começaram a discutir sobre isso e
perguntaram pra mim que eu achava eu fui
assim porque essa escola errada com que
a gente sabe que essa escola é errado
ali não era relevante pra mim e dividiu
a opinião que seria só minha opinião era
muito mais relevante trazer esse
questionamento porque a pessoa que
pensou nessa escola
ela provavelmente se orgulha de passar
pra frente os valores que ela acredita
que está formando meninas dentro desse
estereótipo feminino que para ela deve
ser muito importante
ela provavelmente se orgulha tanto
quanto o mergulho de entrar em sala e
promover de construção
então quem está certo e pra quem eu
posso argumentar
você pode falar assim não parei enquanto
ela está privando diversas formas
questões de gênero e às vezes obrigando
meninas que não se encaixam nesse padrão
ariane obrigadas pela família talvez eu
estou aqui lutando para que cada um
possa expressar da forma como entende
estou tentando quebrar com normas e
padrões mas não adiantou podem aumentar
porque montou podem ter razão
não importa tá certo importa muito mais
questionar de onde vem o nosso conceito
certo e errado porque uma coisa é certa
pra mim errado pra você porque uma mesma
coisa tão defendida por um grupo então
atacado pelo outro
a gente pensa sobre o que é certo e
errado a gente só replica o que foi
ensinado pra mim é fundamental pensar
nisso antes do desejo está certo porque
é esse certo pra maioria que me faz
ouvir que eu sou e moral doente e que eu
não sou um bom exemplo para as crianças
mesmo até no meu priminho e silvinho e
me dando super bem com eles
é esse certo que me faz ouvir pessoas
próximas que é até aceitável mas é
normal não é que está tudo bem comigo e
claro que estaria hoje eu sou o padrão
sou homem hétero branco que está tudo
bem comigo mas através da rua é difícil
aceitar é esse certo que faz uma pessoa
sttrans o frio diariamente discriminação
e violência
vocês não precisam pensar sobre isso
agora não tá
vocês podem pensar em ir para casa
quando deitar a cabeça no travesseiro
não tem problema
agora eu queria propor um exercício
simples
só que antes desse exercício tem que
explicar um conceito que eu não sei se
todo mundo sabe se gênero uma pessoa se
é o oposto de uma pessoa trans é por
exemplo uma pessoa que nasce no corpo
feminino é designado menina nascer e ela
se sente como uma mulher fácil também tá
vamos pensar então vamos imaginar agora
que todos os homens se nascem com vagina
com outro com seios e que todas as
mulheres nascem com pênis com próstata o
que ele está fazendo é inverter os
corpos
a gente tem temos seus corpos a gente
não está invertendo mentalidade em
discurso
então vamos lá com esses corpos
invertidos a gente tem uma nova natureza
uma nova ideologia como que a gente ia
sustentar o discurso se pautam no
nacional
a natureza vou dar um exemplo pra ficar
mais fácil
as mulheres reivindicam o direito de
andar sem camisa também os caras fazem
isso que os caras vão falar
acho que esse mesmo assim a gente pelo
amor de deus
mulher é uma tábua cada mulher nem peito
tem pra quem quer tirar a camisa
a gente está aqui a gente tem volume
fica suando aqui embaixo escorre no meio
é claro que a gente vai tirar a camisa
conta calor
é óbvio agora que mulheres também fica
nessa necessidade de igualá sabiá não
tem bola corpo é diferente pra que isso
por exemplo a gente questionar se porque
o homem tem essa sexualidade tão
aflorada o homem nasce com órgãos só do
prazer vitórias como que não é sexual
está aqui é para usar né tem uma função
é essa é pra lá mulher pra querer sexo
tem que esperar subir pra funcionar nem
sempre sobe agora a gente não
a gente está aqui com esse órgão é um
privilégio um privilégio mas a natureza
que deu pra reclamar com a natureza
outra coisa que falam também que deixei
voltado a mulher questionando a
superioridade masculina o homem gera não
ser o homem da luz
todas as mulheres que estão enviaram de
onde passaram nove meses dentro de um
homem a gente alimentando a gente
passando pela dor do parto a mulher dá
conta desse nó mulher é o sexo frágil
eu poderia dar mil exemplos e até
divertido até sugiro que se expliquem
isso em casa
na verdade a proposta desses pra gente
pensar será que é sobre a natureza sobre
a biologia ou é sobre quem esse discurso
privilegia será que a natureza fosse
assim do jeito que a gente imaginou que
fosse invertida
o discurso seria diferente talvez não
porque para o discurso ser diferente
a mentalidade tem que ser diferente eu
entro em sala e eu encaro cabeças
completamente diferentes da minha
brincar realidades diversas e toda vez
que eu entro eu saio deslocado do lugar
que ocupa
só questionando alguma coisa sai
refletindo seu sobre alguma experiência
que foi dividida
eu não entro em sala pra ensinar sobre
gênero e sexualidade
seria muita prepotência minha parte dos
exercícios dentro pra conversar para
falar e para ouvir também para entender
de onde é que vem a opinião que cada um
emite de onde é que vem a visão que eles
elas têm pensar nisso pra mim me faz
pensar muito sobre verdade mesmo assim é
muito importante que a gente pegue nossa
verdade e deixá lo de lado vamos tirar
verdade daqui e colocar aqui não estou
falando que você abre mão da sua verdade
não é isso você pode andar com a sua
verdade quando você quiser você pode
apresentar outras pessoas você menor
problema
mas você não pode permitir que isso é
verdade que se segue é verdade te impeça
de enxergar o outro que ela tenha à
frente desse outro eu não abri mão do
que eu sou pelos meus pais e eles não
abriram mão das crenças que eles têm os
valores que eles têm por mim
mas a gente chegou na verdade em comum é
a nossa verdade é o amor é brega mas é
isso mesmo
eu não entro em sala pra mudar nem
influenciar os alunos alunos que
discutam eu não tô aqui pra isso também
eu realmente espero que você pensa
diferente de mim mas está disposto a
pensar diferente você mesmo
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]